hi everyone my name is evan chan i'm a
senior data engineer at urban logic
and welcome to my presentation
so urban logic we are
an online platform that provides uh
insights
and we use trust and machine learning
amongst other things
to
give really great
insights for transportation economic
development and other community use
cases
so
why
thin cloud apps
if we look at the progression
of technology through
the recent years we can see that we have
moved from
in the old days we used virtual machines
to
uh now we're using containers everywhere
and we can see
technologies on the horizon
that are coming on fast such as
serverless and web assembly and what we
notice in this trend is that cloud
infrastructure is getting smaller
thinner and more concurrent
right so
things that maybe didn't used to be
quite as important
such as memory and allocations are
becoming more important because when
each unit is smaller you need to be more
efficient
and
you know we also live in a data-rich
world so we need to process more and
more data so that has to be more and
more efficient and finally using less
memory it's more eco-friendly
right
so
the the question for everyone here we're
here to learn about rust is why use rust
for thin cloud apps and
they are actually mainly reasons for
which i personally came to ross i came
to russ from writing a distributed
in-memory database called filodb which
was on the jvm
and
um i came for
the no compromise
aspect of rust
that
it was sold to me that you could get
performance safety and abstractions at
the same time usually you know you have
to choose you know
one or two of these
and
um i found that it was
pretty much mostly true that you you
could have all three things
and also with rust you get great control
over memory usage your allocations
and
you have
many ways to you could even opt out of
using a standard library so there's many
ways that you could use less memory and
that
small profile makes it very appropriate
for writing everything from apps to
oss kernel level code hypervisors and so
on
right however to take advantage of it
you have to learn how to control
and measure the allocations
so
let's dive right in
how rust apps use memory
so let's start by reviewing
rust memory model really quickly
on the left side you see
uh what does rust put on the stack so
they would be
primitives
structs so you have a couple different
fields but but everything in the
structure is fixed size
you also have fixed size arrays
and
pointers references
two things on the heap
so you have some stuff to work with and
then everything else that is dynamic is
put on here
such as vects which are lists and arrays
things like strings and other
more complex
objects
as well as some miscellaneous things
that we'll go over later
now one thing is that rust does not have
a garbage collector so how does it
manage memory
now this this is a really important
point for
folks those of you coming from dynamic
languages this is the biggest
differentiator above rust
what
rust promises
is that
even though it does not have a garbage
collector it will track
how your data is used
through a concept known as a lifetime so
to keep track of
when your data is created when it is
borrowed and used and it tries to
prevent
unsafe
use and sharing of your data
and it tracks when your data is no
longer used so it knows when to free it
right
this talk is not going to be about this
but but this will be important to
remember when we talk about allocating
memory so let's with that let's dive
into some basic
data structures that are used a lot and
how much memory they actually represent
so
we start off with strings and vects so
remember effect is a list of a fixed
type of item
so on the stack
they use
on 64-bit architectures like the x86 and
modern r machines they use 24 bytes the
pointer would be eight bytes and then
there is one field for capacity which is
how
much how many items
this
data show can hold like that is how many
characters for a string or how many
items for back and then there's a length
which is how many items it actually has
right now so these are both global data
structures
now
then
the pointer would point to an area in
the heap that actually holds
the of the items
for the characters
now
the complement to backs and strings
are
slice pointers
and
string slices both of these are
immutable
they are the same uh as the previous
ones except there are 16 bytes because
you have
one pointer and you have a length
because these things cannot grow
so they just point at a location and
they tell you how many items they
represent
now let's look at a more complex
data structure the hashmap so
for a hashmap
this is a bit more complex
a hashmap can be implemented using
buckets
right so all of your items are hashed
into a fixed number of buckets
each bucket in turn
can have
one or more
items in it
when there is a collision
so what we notice here is that the list
of buckets
is basically
a vector of a bucket
and in each slot a bucket
you know that points to a bucket and
then each bucket entry would be
your key and value pairs for the items
and if my hash map is a string
key and a string index that means that
i'm storing
as the key and value
entry in each bucket slot
i'm using
24 bytes for a key uh for the
key string
struct
and 24 bytes for the value string
structs so that added together you know
gives you 48
right and
now assuming that the bucket let's
assume that each bucket has like one
entry for the case where there are no
collisions then if you add in you know
the pointer for the bucket
which is basically the bucket itself is
like effect right it's like a list so
that pointer actually takes up another
24 bytes meaning the overhead is
up to 72 bytes
per entry
um
so one thing you need to be
very very aware of is that for more
complex data structures you have these
nesting of pointers that can create
a non-trivial amount of metadata now if
your items like are large then maybe
this is not a problem but if your items
are small then you might want to be
careful and think about that
now where could you be allocating memory
in your apps
so
we'll go over each of these items in
detail later but um
starting in no random order um
one item that could take up a lot of
memory is serialization that creates a
lot of temporary objects
in other words one is when use traits or
trait objects
when you um we'll go over that
in a minute
and um any time you use clone
and data structures
and and so forth
now um
you could look at your
your app and go through and find out
look at these users but maybe a better
way is the benchmark right so there's
two ways you could benchmark your apps
right so
one is to do dynamic memory analysis
this looks at you know starting from
t0 the time when you start your app
what
is being allocated
um how much and it would track this over
time and it would figure out
hey how you know what what is the even
if you
allocate memory and free it
you know where where are we allocating
freeing memory to most where is what's
the memory churn so that's a dynamic
benchmarking
there's also static
memory analysis
a static heap analysis this you might be
more familiar with if you come from a
gc language like you know java and so
forth where basically you could have an
analyzer that walks your heap and
figures out hey for a given point in
time
uh what memory is being used up what is
using up the most memory now
there are tools for doing dynamic
analysis
one is called heap track another one is
called d-hat and i'll go over examples
of d-hat
static keyboard analysis is a bit more
difficult in rest
we can get overall memory usage pretty
easily
using something like general control
and we can actually diff memory usage
you can also profile data structure
using something called deep size but but
there isn't really anything
um
comprehensive like you have with the jvm
but
i'll show you some stuff you can use for
that
so
um
remember
in rust that usually the more things
that you type like box that the more you
allocate so that's a fun hint
to remember
so let's now let's go over
uh some potentially
supernatural uses of memory and how we
can uh help
reduce it
so
the first thing
is look at your method signatures
what are we passing in
for example
do you see function signatures like this
where i pass an effect of string so this
is quite common you know in order to
process some string lists right
so at first appearance you might like
okay that that's you know a nice
signature but there's two problems
when you
ask the caller to pass in a back of
strings you're basically forcing them to
allocate
twice right ones for the back and once
for each string
instead
if we're able to
uh change the signature to
point at a string string slices
which is the second signature there
where we have this
you know ampersand and unstring
this gives the caller two chances to
avoid allocations one is that they can
point at existing strings instead of
allocating a new string that saves a
whole bunch of memory and the second one
is that they can
pass in a string slice instead of a
slice
of strings instead of a back
right and if you want even more
flexibility you can
change
the signature to
pass in an iterator which gives you the
chance to
for them to pass in even non-less data
structures there's anything that can
provide an iterator for even more
flexibility so that gives you
flexibility and gives you a way to avoid
allocations
so
the
the next thing
is
that
we can try to flatten our data
structures like vac of string backpack
and i'm not going to go over all of
these um but there's a bunch of
crates that will help you there such as
nested
that will save you a lot of storage if
you're if you're trying to
have a bunch of lists of strings for
example and there's a whole bunch of
crates that can help you with um
strings that are basically inlineable
where when you have strings below a
certain size they will be on the heat on
the stack instead of the heat
as well as things like small small back
so there are
ones we're doing smaller
data structures
and i did a test using a repo that you
can
feel free to visit
where i show that by using nested
instead of vec you can save you know
like say 25
you know total
memory allocated
so
another area
is
by reducing clones you might notice many
of you are writing code using async this
is a really popular feature of rust now
you can write code that
you know forks off work and you can do
an await to wait wait for it which is
which is great you might find yourself
however having to clone a lot of data
structures when you're calling your
async functions and these enclosures
because the data that
is passed into a sync because it's a
future and could run on another thread
it needs to be thread safe
one
there's some quick tips one is to
consider using arc instead of clone
and
this is something that makes sense
especially for things like lists things
that where you could pass in a lot of
items clone
will usually do a deep clone
what has to do deep clone is to clone
every item so that could be quite
expensive using arc
does cost you
a
an atomic you know couple atomic
operations and it saves you a lot of
memory
another
idea is to use
something like an actor pattern this is
where you try to keep your state local
instead of
passing your state around and so you
keep your data
structures within each actor or
equivalently within each thread and you
use channels to communicate
and you pass
you know small messages and events only
so that's a pattern that can help and it
has other benefits as well finally we
consider using something like cow
for example if you want to escape
strings such as you want to
um like
for
urls or something else where a lot of
times the string is not changed but
sometimes you need to create a new copy
well instead of creating a new copy
every time you can just copy only on
right right
well so how slow is arc really right
like in case you're worried about using
arc instead of cloning well
well if the data is anything concise
it's you know it is fast it is you know
almost always faster uh actually but
basically arc is just an atomic
increment on the clone and then the
document on drop and roughly on an x86
they estimate that this is between 30
and 120 nanoseconds depending on which
level of cash
it might be faster and other hardware
so
um
now
here's another area where
you might be using memory is you might
find that you have a signature like this
where you're processing some item
and you know you want to pass the
different implementations of traits
right so you make your signature have
this dime keyword for dying my trade
right and now in order to be able to
pass that function usually you need to
box it which means you need to allocate
some heap memory for that unfortunately
that means that every time you're
calling this method you're
you're doing this allocation which is
not the fastest thing
right so especially in a hot loop
one trade one crate sorry that you can
use that helps a lot is called enum
dispatch which is
really great
what it does is if all of your trade
implementations are within your control
you can make it any num
and
all of your implementations of my
behavior in this case are
in this enum might be really numb what
we do is that we would
annotate it with enum dispatch and enum
dispatch will will magically it will
tie in with the trait
and it will actually make it so that
your enum
will implement
the trait methods if all of the variants
of the numbers also implement
so
basically you can change the signature
here to process my behavior you know and
you can still call my method on it on
all the variants that pass in this this
is a tremendous performance boost and it
reduces allocations too so this is
really really great
i love it and i use it in
one crate of mine
so
another area where
we
could allocate a lot is
are with sterilization
right so
let's look at a quick sample certainly
json
with the deceleration from raw json to
an intermediate
value type
this certi json value thing this is
quite common
for serialization libraries and then it
has to do another step it has to take
this intermediate
ir and create a you know say struct or
something right
so
um one way that you could go with this
uh is uh to
uh use
there are some faster crates such as
json russ
where the intermediate representations
are more efficient like json rush has a
short value type where short strings are
on the stack so this makes
it
faster use less memory
you can also go to binary protocols
although many of them have the same
problem they need to translate to some
intermediate layer or something but but
some of them can translate directly to
you know say a struct or something like
that
however i think the best strategy is
just to avoid civilization altogether no
serialization so what does this mean
evan this is what you would ask what
does it mean
what we mean is using something like
flat buffers you might have heard of it
captain proto
apache arrow
it does take some work to actually
create these formats but what is usually
meant is that there's no deserialization
meaning once i create a flat buffer
i can send it over the wire
when i get it
you know i can actually examine the flat
buffer directly from the network buffers
and extract values out
without creating
another into you know without
translating and deserializing it to my
final form
so this is really fast it you know
usually you can do no copy or no
decentralization this is really really
good
and i highly recommend it
so just an example from
prostate json
that
sorry
that um
in this case
uh using my laptop and again
the comparison is available in this repo
that i have
and i used
d-hat for heat profiling
what we find is that
using
json rust where it would reduce the
maximum heat used
so d-hat actually measures
how much heap is used at the point where
in the max of when the heap is
the largest in your application runtime
and we can see that it is quite a bit
faster too it's like maybe 37
you know one-third faster because it has
to allocate less uh and again this is
the technique of using
visualization where uh it
uses a stack value a short string
right and if you used no serialization
it would be much faster than that
um however uh for some reason the total
allocations you know does not uh go down
this is like basically alloc free alert
free so on
and just to show you i think this is uh
good to show you what the d-hat output
looks like
um
it basically gives you the top notes
at a certain time but you can look at
what are the top allocators for all time
and
it will tell you it will give you a
stack trace here we can see that the
stock trace you can usually trace it to
30. json when you know basically
creating json objects that is using up
that is
90 of your allocations
and it will tell you things like what is
the average size fit allocations and the
lifetimes that on average is 73
microseconds
so it gives you a lot of really useful
memory profiling information okay
and just really quickly we'll talk about
a few extra memory allocation topics
in russ you can switch to memory
allocator
there are two popular alternatives to
the standard allocator one is j malloc
which came from
well it originally came from
bsd sorry
but it was popularized by facebook
and was created for reducing
fragmentation and concurrency
it does have a bit of overhead in terms
of memory used but it is
faster than the standard allocator
another one to check out is called
wemalloc from microsoft it is designed
to be a small secure replacement for
malik and in practice i do believe it is
also faster
so
you can check that out
and i have a benchmark that shows that
sometimes it is faster
okay finally
for certain
use cases
you can use bombo arena allocators
and um
usually this is when
for special cases where
you know let's let's say uh you want a
sandbox some memory for a part of your
app you know for queries in a database
or a certain name spaces that kind of
thing you can just take this elegant
memory by bumping the pointer and then
you can free it all at once so for these
things there's a crate called bumpalo
which is which is really great
and that can help sometimes
when you want to control memory use
finally you might be like evan so
reducing keep allocation is great but i
want to actually make my binary smaller
you should check out the cargo bloat
crate this will analyze your
rust binaries and
figure out where
is your space being used
but there are tons of ways that you
could actually reduce you could get down
to really really small like well below
megabyte
binaries you can check out this and by
the way
the slides
will be shared and you can actually
click you should be able to click on
them
there's a url so
there is a blog that gives many things
for reducing the size of binary
including stripping reducing debug
things
optimizing for size instead of speed
and uh if you really want to remove the
standard library that's a way you can
get down to extremely small like c sized
things but be
warned that that has a lot of trade-offs
and i'm not quite sure if they are uh
worth it but it depends on the use case
so um
thank you very much you can feel free to
reach out to me on
instagram
sorry twitter instagram
github etc